Peter Pan and fairies we're ready
we're gonna have fun are you ready
hey good morning good morning today is
day four of our trip we're going to
Disney today so today is our day one in
Magic Kingdom let's go
[Music]
we're gonna take the monorail to go to
the park
all right we are in we are in day one of
our Magic Kingdom day
all right our first ride of the day is
fake Thunder Mountain five minutes wait
let's see if it's five minutes away
[Music]
all right the Thunder Mountain is fun it
was so good we have fun and then now
we're off to next ride the Splash
Mountain we're gonna get wet but not all
wet let's go
[Music]
someone's all right Evan
was fun yeah it got soaked yeah you got
so too I did too well she sat in the
front seat yeah and the front seat gets
soaked but she's had in the front seat
by herself yeah and so the seat in front
of me was empty so I got soaked that's
love
let's go
the pirate Rye has opened so we're gonna
go to that right now
foreign
still close so we're going to Jungle
Cruise yay
all right Jungle Cruise wait time is an
hour
yay yay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah all right next up let's go
I don't know where
Pirates hope it's open they said third
time is a chance let's go
[Music]
the pirate right was not bad they let us
go into the express lane I don't know
maybe because Evan and I were being nice
to each other so that's why they gave us
okay you guys can go there
that was nice all right we're going to
the Harbor House for lunch Columbia
Harbor House
[Music]
hello thank you for the lunch I got a
lobster bro highest rated Lunch Spot in
Disney because I wanted Nina to be happy
so she got a lobster roll thank you it's
good I'll share I'll share Trio good
yeah I remember I had it was like shrimp
and chicken and something
we're here now we're going to split up
Nina's taking the boys back on some
rides yeah I'm taking the Catherine to
the 12 foot under activities Peter Pan
let's go baby
all right what's happening Catherine
Peter Pan going to the Peter Pan ride
the boys and Nina are going to go back
on the fun uh big rides and it's back to
12 and under crew let's go
ten
and fairies we're ready let's do it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right Catherine what do we think
great great yeah all right what's up
next
uh find auntie and Jeffrey and Hayden
and go to ice cream ice cream yeah ice
cream and then shopping let's go all
right we got ice cream for desserts
Citrus World Citrus swirl yummy
yummy yummy oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for watching
today we're going to Animal Kingdom and
if you want to see what we're doing
click right here it's a good video we'll
see you there